yes our next internet warrior has
literally lost his words Taylor Albert
from Utah was near the top of
Argentina's tallest peak when he became
tongue-tied speech is a very complicated
task that speech is very complicated
well we don't have any wizards but we do
have scientists so luckily his friends
have realized that his inability to
speak is not just something funny for
them to film it's a potential symptom of
altitude sickness which can lead to
high-altitude cerebral edema the brain
even though it's only about three pounds
it takes out about 25% of the oxygen
that we breathe in so the first thing
that's going to notice a lack of oxygen
is the brain at high altitudes about
capillaries leak out fluid into the
tissue but this is a problem because you
have the Scala outside so the brain
can't just get bigger and bigger and
with that increased pressure there's
just nowhere for the brain to go it
shifts around within the skull there's
potential for huge damage there this
finally will lead to death try to treat
this altitude sickness there's a certain
drug called isettas Olamide that
acidifies the blood and increases
respiration so you get more oxygen
coming into your body but most
importantly they take him to a lower
altitude where he has more oxygen
available to him naturally there's
mostly over
that's a cool view to wear